head forester
andreas palmer is conducting an
experiment for his guests
imagine we're all little trees we're all
spruce saplings all close together just
like in nature
and because we're trees we don't just
want to grow up we want to spread our
branches too
so let's all stand up and spread our
arms and
you see how tight it gets lesson number
one
in nature the stronger one prevails
always
the problem here is too many spruces and
too few silver furs
the forester explains the fur's benefits
you see what a fat root this is like a
carrot he says
it illustrates well that these trees can
reach more different minerals in the
ground
deeper water reserves in the summer
making them simply the more stable trees
they're comparable with oak trees on the
flat plains
the oak epitomizes sturdiness in lowland
forests
and up here it's the fur
ten women and four men are spending a
week outdoors to help the forest and
protect the valuable furs
only a few grow as tall as these
young furs are a delicacy for deers and
stags that wander through
nibbling off the buds stunting their
growth says andreas palmer
and that puts other trees at an
advantage
and where furs and spruces coexist
animals seem to always prefer eating the
furs
there is no vacation these volunteers
have booked a week of hard forestry work
one participant says they're going to
learn how to wrap the furs in wool
that's supposed to protect young
saplings against being bitten off
but before work can start more
instructions
the helpers are getting chilly and
impatient but the chief forester wants
to make sure
everyone knows how it's done right
here
looks easy but it's not even finding the
baby furs in the forest is a problem
the rule of thumb is spruce's sting furs
don't
project manager andreas friesica
observes and criticizes
that's not going to work he tells ronnie
the volunteer
the sapling might not be bitten off but
there's so much wool it won't grow next
season
use less and ronnie asks even less than
that
carolyn says she loves it here it's
fascinating
it's a lot of work but she thinks it's
great to achieve something through
simple means
stopping the deer from coming and
destroying the trees
i find their enthusiasm for each tiny
tree astonishing
but unlike the volunteers this is my
first time here
everyone in the group takes up the
burden once a year to work for germany's
forests
yesterday at the train station at johann
georgenstadt in saxony
it was all a big welcome back these
people know each other
weeks in the woods together forge bonds
some are here for the eighth time
participants pay
only for travel here explains project
leader andreas friesica
room and board are free anyone should be
able to join
forestry authorities cover 40 of the
costs the rest
come from donations and sponsors
andreas friesica welcomes everyone to
their lodgings on behalf of the project
he says when they go in they can decide
among themselves who will sleepwear the
accommodation is on the level of a youth
hostel
with several people to a room pure
luxury says the team
i notice a hot water bottle cecelia
laughs and says
just in case but the rooms seem to be
plenty warm here
next morning 6 a.m preparing to plant
fur saplings
these outsized tools are called mattocks
they're needed to cut a proper hole in
the ground for planting
each one weighs four kilos in the course
of the day
they easily feel much heavier
the day's objective is ambitious
500 plantings says andreas we should
make it but we'll see
the rest get put into moist soil
together so they don't dry out by
tomorrow
the official objective for the week is
to plant two thousand
new silver furs the forester has
only five employees covering a huge area
so he's glad for the extra help
these tiny furs are already three years
old
now care is needed the roots have to
stay undamaged
most of these saplings won't survive for
every 25
thirds that are planted only one on
average makes it
the project leader says it all depends
on how much wildlife there is
and on other factors the amount of
snowfall how dry the summer is
whether other trees will fall on it
there are a whole lot of factors that
influence whether a little sapling
like this grows to maturity
i'm surprised at how bad the odds slowly
i begin to understand why the crew were
taking so much care with the wool
earlier on
back in the woods chief forrester palmer
introduces the crew to the craft of
planting trees
the matic is an unwieldy tool but
carolyn gets the hang of it
together she a teacher and ronnie a
truck driver
are a dream team
dig out the hole plant the fur
and check for stability all in neat rows
with a meter and a half of space in
between
i ask carolyn what's the hardest part of
planting
she says it's making the hole because
usually there's some kind of surprise
involved
a rock or a root
here it gets tough as straight as
possible as deep as possible
and losing as little soil as possible
keeps the troops fed while they toil
away he's responsible for a hot lunch
not so easy out here in the wild
first he gets only smoke but then the
flames catch
carolyn and ronnie have developed a real
rhythm their furs
stand proud
berlin native ronnie says nothing beats
nature
and if there's anything he can do for it
it's here with the forest project
lunchtime finally comes at 2 30 but the
break
is a short one reaching today's goal of
500 plantings
is looking pretty unlikely
but they go for it anyway
anyone who can and wants to can work
alone quality remains top priority
the volunteers are slower than
professional forestry workers
but they compensate through their
motivation and the sheer fact they're
here
ninety percent of their plants take root
the professionals work in pairs and
manage only 65 percent
bianca says it's hard work getting the
ground ready but it's also very nice
work
why is that i ask she says she was
telling wilfred earlier
it's like building a nest for these baby
trees
she doesn't know whether their efforts
will produce results
by now the matics feel very heavy indeed
elisa and cecilia are having a tough
time of it
what's the problem i ask cecilia says
it's a giant nugget
elisa says the rock has to be removed
but it's stuck
it's become a personal struggle for them
i'd have started digging elsewhere
long ago
finally elisa says they've got the right
technique
i ask is it fun or hard it's both they
agree
but it's not enough for the project
leader darkness falls in an hour
there's still plenty of plants to go and
they're all so puny
andrea says each sapling gets a shock
from being replanted and it has to
adjust to its new environment
that weakens the plant it's called
planting
shock and it depends how big the shock
is
when it goes into the ground weakened
the likelihood it will survive the shock
is even lower
the ground here is simply too tough
uneven and full of rocks and roots
no easy job for beginners by evening 160
saplings are left unplanted
the kitchen crew is waiting for the
volunteers return
dinner is all organic to fortify the
workers for tomorrow
they're here another four days as their
good deed
for the forest